Pierre Palmade avait acheté une maison à
Cély-en-Bière en 2017 pour fuir
justement ce monde de la nuit le monde
des nuits parisiennes avec la coque etc
et en fait ça n'a pas fonctionné
puisqu'il organisait des fêtes danse
dans sa maison qui est donc en
Seine-et-Marne et à une heure de Paris
en voiture et ce vendredi 10 février
il était avec au moins quatre copains
quatre amis
lorsque il faisait la fête depuis au
moins 24 heures d'après les voisins et
il découvre que le frigo est vide et
donc ils ont besoin de de s'alimenter
d'aller faire des courses et alors
qu'ils avaient consommé
beaucoup de de produits stupéfiants il
prend sa voiture qui est une 3008 il
part avec deux individus qu'on recherche
d'ailleurs actuellement ils vont faire
les courses au supermarché du coin et
c'est au retour
alors que c'est la une petite
départementale des 372 qui est qui est
tout droite enfin c'est assez
impressionnant qu'on puisse avoir un
accident sur cette route là il va se
déporter pour des raisons que j'ignore
se déporté sur la gauche et
avoir un choc frontal avec un autre
véhicule qui était conduit par un homme
de 40 ans son fils était à l'arrière un
fils de 6 ans et en passager une femme
enceinte âgée de 26 ans qui était
enceinte de 7 mois donc un choc terrible
un choc frontal terrible
très rapidement les secours sont arrivés
sur place mais entre temps les deux
passagers qui étaient les amis fêtards
alors il y en a un qui disent que c'est
des escorteboles en fait on n'en sait
rien puisqu'on les a pas retrouvés
ont pris la fuite
et ils sont probablement alors il y
avait plusieurs raisons possiblement
soit ils étaient chargés c'est avec de
la cam sur eux et ils avaient pas
forcément envie que les gendarmes
découvrent ça et ensuite deuxième raison
probablement pour aller faire le ménage
dans la maison de Pierre Palmade pour
faire disparaître le maximum de traces
de leur passage donc vous pensez que ce
sont eux qui sont allés tout nettoyer
chez Perpignan puisque apparemment il y
avait plus rien dans la maison alors les
policiers qui ont assez compliqué est-ce
qu'il y avait la police à la gendarmerie
il y a deux ans qui est ouverte une
enquête pour l'accident une enquête pour
le trafic de stup donc les gendarmes
sont en charge saisies du trafic de stup
et la police de Melun chargée de des
circonstances accidents donc
c'est pas forcément la meilleure
configuration de mettre deux services
qui ne s'entendent pas forcément bien
donc les gendarmes ont fait une
perquisition ils ont dans le cadre de
leur affaire de stups ils ont saisi le
téléphone portable capable de Pierre
Palmade et les policiers sont venus eux
aussi faire une perquisition domicile de
Pierre Palmade ils ont pas trouvé le
téléphone et ils en ont déduit que
c'était les deux
les deux jeunes qui étaient partis avec
finalement ces gendarmes qui avaient le
téléphone voilà donc je pense que ça
aurait été mieux de mettre qu'un seul
service pour s'occuper de tout ça aurait
été mais ça le problème exactement alors
aujourd'hui on va revenir sur cette
affaire on a parlé de 24 heures de fait
c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est quoi Gilles parce que les éléments
la fête aurait démarré le jour d'avant
effectivement avec quatre autres
personnes dans cette maison ce sera un
endroit très festif alors que s'est-il
passé est-ce qu'il y a eu consommation
notamment de produits qui s'appelle le
camsexe pour favoriser justement alors
c'est ce que c'est ce qui se dit c'est
quoi cette histoire
de camicole et sexual je veux dire des
produits chimiques et une activité
sexuelle on prend des drogues on prend
des substances pour être performant
sexuellement pour faciliter les rapports
pour avoir les fantasmes les plus fous
et souvent dans les parties comme ça
c'est les parties comme ça les drogues
c'est les drogues du Ken sexe et on va
on va faire on va faire des marathons ce
qu'on appelle des marathons sexuels ça
peut durer moi je soigner des patients
qui faisaient 96 heures d'affilée le
marathon quoi d'accord avec c'est avec
ce que c'est avec des produits ils
prennent des drogues donc c'est quelle
est la dangerosité de tes produits la
dangerosité de ces produits c'est des
produits stimulants des produits
aphrodisiaque c'est toutes des drogues
des catinomes de synthèse comme la pro
MMC de la cocaïne il y a des
facilitateurs d'érection des médicaments
principi d'érection il y a les poppers
il y a du GHB et on mélange tout et on
vient un surhum sexuel ou une surface
parce que ça existe aussi chez les
femmes d'accord
et donc ça peut créer effectivement des
effets secondaires terribles alors on va
aller jusqu'à la mort mais ça peut aussi
créer un état de panique des
hallucinations qui fait que vous ne
savez plus du tout ce que vous faites où
vous allez ce qui pourrait
éventuellement correspondre à une perte
de contrôle enfin etc mais apparemment
apparemment effectivement il y aurait eu
il y aurait eu un conditionnel
consommation de tels produits dans la
maison de Pierre Palmade à Céliane bien
oui j'en arrive je voulais réagir oui
bah je voulais juste rappeler que cette
drogue notamment la cocaïne te permet
par exemple pourquoi ça dure 24 heures
ou même 48 heures c'est que tu peux
passer une nuit blanche sans aucun
problème tu es ivre mort tu prends de la
cocaïne cette dissoule tu continues la
soirée ça la soirée ne s'arrête jamais
ça veut dire qu'au bout de deux nuits
blanches et parfois trois tu n'es plus
qu'un fantôme il y a un moment tu sais
même plus de toi mais tu es à qui tu
parles et tout pierre pas mal de
problèmes y compris dans sa maison de
les gens abusé de la situation parce que
après de nuit sans sommeil bah tu et moi
un vigilant sur tout ce qui se passe
dans dans ta maison donc ça c'était un
truc régulier qui se qui se passait ce
que je voudrais dire par rapport à cette
affaire je suis très embêté moi pour
parler parce que Pierre j'ai toujours
aimé comme un frère
c'est deux choses c'est d'abord c'est ma
compassion pour les victimes de cet
accident qui sont pour rien ça c'est
important justement on va donner des
infos donc le producteur de la voiture
percuté a été transporté dans un état
grave mais son état de santé ce sera
amélioré hier il est désormais hors de
danger son fils un enfant de 6 ans a été
héliporté lui aussi vers l'hôpital
spécialisé de Necker à Paris il aurait
été éjecté du véhicule lors de l'impact
et serait toujours dans un état grave et
la sœur du conducteur une femme enceinte
de 26 ans était transportée dans un état
grave elle aussi à l'hôpital
Beaujon de Clichy par hélicoptère
malheureusement c'est un drame
puisqu'elle a perdu son bébé elle est
enceinte de près de 7 mois Jean-Marie
oui donc c'est la première chose c'est
c'est que bon ces gens là ont subi un
drame absolument épouvantable et la
deuxième chose que je suis obligé de
dire c'est que Pierre Palmade et
responsable à 100% de cet accident donc
les les conclusions en dehors de prier
de souhaiter que ces gens-là non
seulement ne meurent pas pas trop c'est
trop de séquelles trop grave
j'imagine qu'elle a été comment on a
pratiqué une césarienne sûrement sur
elle puisque au moment où ça a dû faire
exploser le la planche qui retenait
l'enfant vraisemblablement mais en tout
cas la justice dit que tu n'es pas une
personne tant que tu n'es pas sorti du
ventre de sa mère tu n'as pas respiré
mais bon
la justice moi je voilà là on pense
surtout à cette dame qui a perdu son
enfant c'était la justice aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elles s'en fout totalement ce
qu'elle dit c'est que elle a perdu son
enfant et que c'est extrêmement grave
c'est vraiment c'est c'est un
traumatisme incroyable pour elle pour le
papa pour et pour tous les gens qui qui
qui ont eu vendent de de cette affaire
Michel donc
aujourd'hui
Pierre Palmade il était dans un état
grave il est sorti de il est sorti
d'affaires apparemment oui ça va
beaucoup mieux c'est ces jours ne sont
pas en danger il était en pronostic
vital engagé au début et se pronostic a
été levé par les médecins et on pense
qu'il pourra être entendu parler
enquêteurs en milieu de semaine
qu'est-ce qui respire pas le mal il
risque il risque à deux titres il risque
gros sur un plan pénal en fonction de
d'un certain nombre de de d'éléments il
risque entre 7 et 10 ans de prison et
entre 100 et 150 entre 15 et non entre
mince entre 10000 et 15000 euros
d'amende ça j'ai envie de vous dire que
c'est la partie facile sans transformer
pardon ça c'est la partie facile de ce
dossier il est poursuivi pour l'instant
il y a une ouverture d'information pour
homicide
par
homicide involontaire
juridiquement c'est assez compliqué si
vous voulez que je développe là dessus
on ne tue pas un être qui n'existe pas
on ne peut pas commettre un homicide sur
un autre qui n'existe pas alors l'enfant
tant qu'il est dans le ventre de sa mère
il n'existe pas il n'a pas de
d'existence d'état civil donc pour que
ça puisse fonctionner juridiquement il
faudrait qu'il soit sorti du ventre de
sa mère qu'il est respirait et qu'il
meurt alors donc on n'y est pas il y
avait deux fuyards de personnes qui
étaient dans la voiture Palmade
aujourd'hui il y a le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui l'ont assommé de se
rendre parce que apparemment il y aurait
des vidéos qui tourneraient voilà
aujourd'hui ils peuvent être poursuivis
aussi est-ce qu'ils sont ils sont pas
encore rendus apparemment écoutez à
l'heure où je vous parle ils étaient pas
ils avaient pas été interpellé je pense
que ça va aller assez vite à partir du
moment où les policiers ont saisi le
téléphone portable de Pierre Palmade
ils vont par la téléphonie les
identifier et a priori les interpeller
ça me semble pas très compliqué
après ce qui risque il y a non
assistance à personne en danger
évidemment et puis ce qu'ils ont fait
entre le moment de l'accident et
quand ils sont passés à la maison ils
ont la maison est-ce qu'ils ont fait le
ménage fait disparaître de la cam c'est
possiblement aussi des dealers c'est
peut-être eux qui approvisionnaient
Pierre Palmade en produits stupéfiants
en fait pour l'instant c'est un peu tôt
parce qu'on n'en sait rien mais la
police les recherches activement et
maintenant qu'on a le téléphone de
Pierre Palmade à mon avis ça va pas
traîner alors on a quelqu'un qui va
venir nous rejoindre dans un instant
puisque
vous pouvez le dire sur le c'est un
drame voilà il y a tellement on parlait
tellement de Pierre Palmas depuis des
années des années même il disait Mathieu
qui avait de gros problèmes dans un
instant on va recevoir Jérémy l'ancienne
amende
même depuis
1988 donc je l'aime quand avec ses hauts
avec ses bas avec voilà on a tous les
deux
changer il a fait un gros travail sur
lui m'a fait peur beaucoup Monsieur
bien sûr bien sûr qu'on a peur bien sûr
mais ils s'en sont moins bien que moi
parce que moi je ne suis pas seule quand
il y a quelqu'un c'est quand même ça n'a
rien à voir